[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este especial de
France 24 con motivo del primer año de
la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania Aunque la
llamada operación especial de Vladimir
Putin comenzó el 24 de febrero de 2022
las tensiones entre estos dos países
datan de años atrás pasando Desde las
protestas del euro maidan hasta la
guerra en el don Vasco en el siguiente
capítulo repasaremos los inicios de este
conflicto
31 de diciembre de 2013 mientras el
mundo recibe el año nuevo en Ucrania en
los árboles de navidad se mezclan con
barricadas es el día número 41 de la que
se conoce como revolución del euromaida
[Aplausos]
kiev Ucrania 21 de noviembre de 2013
horas tensas después de que el gobierno
del presidente ucraniano Pro ruso Víctor
yanukkovic anunciara que no un acuerdo
de asociación con la Unión Europea y que
en su lugar planea incorporarse a la
unión aduanera euroasiática liderada por
moscúl
la decisión de suspender la preparación
de la firma del acuerdo de asociación y
zona de libre comercio con la Unión
Europea es dura
Pero la única posible en la difícil
situación económica actual que tenemos
[Aplausos]
miles de ucranianos salen a las calles
las protestas en su mayoría pacíficas se
llevan a cabo en la plaza de maidán en
kiev
[Música]
con el paso de los días las protestas
toman un tono violento y se recrudecen
ante la brutal represión de la vercut la
policía antidisturbios que deja cerca de
100 civiles muertos en casi dos meses
del movimiento
[Música]
occidente se solidariza con las
protestas Rusia denuncia un intento de
golpe de nacionalista ucranianos
financiado por Estados Unidos
finalmente el 22 de febrero de 2014 y
anukovic huye a Rusia
[Música]
mientras la adrenalina baja en kiev en
el este y sur de Ucrania crecen los
movimientos prorusos alentados desde
Moscú
la primera manzana de la discordia es
crimea la Península del mar Negro que
nikitano a Ucrania en los años 50 el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin toma la
Península por la fuerza y organiza un
referendo para su anexión a Rusia el
resultado oficial 97% a favor las
potencias occidentales lo declaran
ilegal el 18 de marzo de 2014 Putin
firma la incorporación de crimea a su
territorio
divierte tiempo no crean a los que
intimían con Rusia y gritan que otras
regiones seguirán después de crimea no
queremos la ruptura de Ucrania no la
necesitamos
tras la anexión occidente impone tibia
sanciones a Moscú y decide sacarlo del
grupo del g8 en adelante el g7
el separatismo Pro ruso armado se
apodera enseguida de parte de las
regiones de lugans El bastión minero e
Industrial del Don Bass poblado
mayoritariamente por rusos al este de
Ucrania el nuevo gobierno ucraniano
responde con una operación militar y
Moscú apoya a los separatistas que se
declaran el 12 de mayo de 2014
repúblicas independientes
el 25 de mayo el empresario Pro
occidental
petroporochenko sale victorioso de las
elecciones presidenciales
las primeras medidas que implementará mi
equipo al comienzo y mi mandato tendrán
como objetivo terminar con la guerra
terminar con el caos y traer la paz a
Ucrania
el 17 de julio un avión de maleya
Airlines es derribado por un misil sobre
el territorio del este de Ucrania
controlado por fuerzas Pro rusas
causando la muerte de la cerca de 300
personas a bordo la investigación de
Países Bajos concluyó que el avión fue
derribado por un misil antiaéreo book
transportado desde Rusia
Moscú siempre ha negado su
responsabilidad
meses de negociaciones llevaron con la
intervención de Francia y Alemania a la
firma del protocolo de Minsk A fines de
2014 y luego en febrero de 2015 a que
Putin y poroshenko suscribieran el
llamado mins 2 ambos incluían un cese al
fuego y otras prohibiciones que nunca
fueron completamente respetadas y el
conflicto continuó aunque con menor
intensidad
[Música]
a comienzos de 2019 en las elecciones
presidenciales traen un desenlace de
película
un joven cómico bolodimir zeleyanski
arruina la reelección de poroschenko y
queda al mando de un país al borde de la
guerra
post a todos los países posoviéticos les
digo
míranos todo es posible
tras esta elección la pandemia de
covid-19 frenó gran parte de los
conflictos del mundo sin embargo una vez
superada la crisis sanitaria de 2020 el
conflicto en Ucrania regresaría con más
fuerza
Recuerden que a lo largo de esta semana
estaremos presentando una programación
especial con motivo del primer año de la
invasión rusa en Ucrania mañana esperen
el segundo capítulo de La cronología de
esta guerra
[Música]